this next speaker spoke at the
conference in 2018
and at the time
he said that he would learn italian for
his girlfriend
well it is now
three years later
and he's completed the italian class on
duolingo and has an 830 day streak i
hope this conference doesn't ruin the
streak you got to keep that going
everyone please welcome adam
the opportunities that we have to make
mental health care a lot more effective
one thing that we do at spring that i
really love and that i'm going to
continue even for external things is i
like to share a testimonial from members
um because i think that kind of um
you know every day you wake up and you
know you roll out of bed and you roll
onto your laptop and you have to
get pumped up for the day and i think
that this is something that really helps
me you know stay motivated and stay
driven with work and so i want to kind
of share that um
with everyone else so uh this quote came
in from a person who works at general
mills which is one of our customers and
they said i had a point in december
where i didn't want to get out of bed in
the morning i had restless nights due to
extreme anxiety and i was not myself at
work or at home i'm reaching out for a
lifeline today during my first
discussion with account navigator uh to
help to get help and to find myself
again for both my family my work and me
we can't navigate it made me feel like i
wasn't starting this journey alone and
that therapy was going to help taking no
action wasn't an option anymore and i'm
so grateful for the ease and support
that spring health is providing so that
i can find my best self again
um i'd like to take a moment just to um
to put a voice to some of the numbers
that we talk about
so spring is a company uh i founded
about uh six almost six years ago five
and a half years ago now uh we're based
in new york we have about 250 employees
now going on 400 by the end of the year
uh we help individuals and organizations
thrive by eliminating every barrier to
mental health uh the company's uh grown
quite considerably we've raised over 100
million dollars uh we serve about two
million patients uh right now and soon
to be 11 million patients
and large employers around the world but
particularly in the us uh basically pay
us to to help um
help them deliver a mental health
benefit so if you work at places like
whole foods instacart general mills
pfizer gap you know pepsi um adobe
uh
all of those kind of companies they've
now like adopted this model where they
entrust a company like spring uh to help
deliver and administer all of the mental
health uh benefits that their employees
and their family members can get access
to
uh and those companies pay us uh
primarily because mental health care in
2021 still and in the united states uh
is a pretty frustrating and broken
experience
uh in general it starts too late uh
people you know they feel bad they're
not sure why uh there's a lot of
confusion uh there's a lot of stigma uh
they you know they may not know they may
not have the right vocabulary to know
what they're going through but they know
that they're not feeling the way that
they used to feel
you know hopefully they do seek
treatment and uh you know by
extraordinary fortune some of them
actually get in front of a provider they
see the provider they get diagnosed you
know they tell them you know all the
problems that they've been facing and
about 30 of those people drop out at
that point it's never to be seen again
70 of them do they go they see that
provider the provider gives them a
treatment something like uh medications
like ssris or maybe therapy talk therapy
different kinds of therapy um
and about 30 of them will actually
recover so 70 of them don't recover you
know they go back to the doctor the
doctor says okay well let's try
something else try you know therapy this
time or let's try meds let's try a
different med and this time they have a
25 chance of getting better you know
they go away for three or four months
they try that treatment again they come
back and it didn't work again and that
was only a 20 chance they get better
over this whole you know trial and error
process eventually the majority of
people do do get better somehow um
although the process is really
uncomfortable for them but then we know
that statistically a year later about 40
of them will have relapsed and so they
end up sick again and so this whole this
whole process of trying to get access to
care of trying to find the right care
for you of trying to find a treatment
that's going to work well for you is
really really frustrating in the u.s and
so um you know that's that's really what
we're here to try and solve for
customers and for members uh throughout
the world
you know it's not a pretty picture but
it is worth knowing that things have
been getting better right it was only 80
years ago when we still had asylums and
kind of the primary treatment for mental
health conditions
involved physical restraint it was about
30 50 years ago when we had the
invention of antidepressants or the
discovery of antidepressants uh when we
developed a lot of the the kind of the
core techniques that we use now in talk
therapy like cognitive behavioral
therapy or interpersonal therapy uh and
today we're in this situation where you
know treatments work on average right we
know that medications do work when you
go and put them through a clinical trial
or we know that therapy does kind of
work
and people do statistically get better
on average uh but there's still so much
trial and error right people go in they
try med they have side effects they come
back it doesn't work and they try
therapy and they don't like the
therapist or they try a different kind
of therapy and then that eventually
works and and so it does work but it's
really clunky and there's this whole um
you know there's this huge phenomenon of
trial and error which delays you know
successful recovery and also increases
costs because it's prolonging the cost
of treatment
and so you know ultimately at spring i
think we have this vision that we can do
a lot more and i think that mental
health care in the future will be a lot
more proactive i think it will be a lot
more predictive and i hope that it will
be a lot more effective and i think that
we can do all of these things uh using
technologies like our
you know using tools from statistics and
data science and so
today i'm going to go over three
examples where r and data science are
improving mental health uh all of these
things alive today uh these are all
examples that you know that you could
contribute to if you were really
interested but just wanted to pick three
different examples the first one is
around this concept of personalizing
treatment
i'm talking about
you know statistical tools and
frameworks that we've developed that can
help us understand what treatment is
most likely to work for you specifically
rather than you know proving that a
treatment works on average
the second is technology that we
developed uh to really enrich the
treatment process to really try and get
at this question of what is our vital
sign in mental health if you have
diabetes we know that we track the
amount of sugar in your blood and we
kind of follow that during treatment and
we maybe change the treatment to try and
uh you know either raise your blood
sugar level or lower your blood sugar
level and try and keep it in the right
bounds and we kind of know what good
looks like and we know what bad looks
like we don't really have that in mental
health and so you know a lot of the work
that we do is really around tracking
outcomes and trying to come up with this
vital sign and really determining
whether treatment is actually working
for people
uh and then the third i want to share
some new stuff that we've been doing
over the last few years around pay for
performance so once we have this vital
sign and we've figured out you know
who's having a good outcome who's having
a bad outcome can we actually um
can we actually pay providers figure out
who which providers are doing the best
job and pay them more and then the
people who are not doing you know the
best job can we train them and help them
do a better job in the future
and so that's all work um that out that
i'll share that has been developed by um
by people that spring in the last couple
of years
so we'll start out with this uh this
concept of personalizing treatment uh if
you're really interested you can go and
check out a paper that we published in
the lancet back in 2016 uh there's a
little screenshot in the top right
clinicians have so many treatment
options if you show up to a doctor say
you go and see a psychiatrist super well
trained psychiatrist they have so many
different things that they can do there
are dozens of different medications that
have all been approved by the fda there
are dozens of different uh you know
psychotherapies or talk therapies that
they can use some of them are very
solutions focused some of them might
talk a lot about your feelings some of
you might talk a lot about your
relationship so there are all of these
different styles that can go into it but
that clinician doesn't really know
what's going to work for you and so
often they'll say things like let's
start with lexapro or let's start with
therapy and then they see if that works
out
um
you know
the kind of the core concept behind this
paper was to try and see if we could use
information that we could that we could
get from patients before they go into
treatment and see if we could predict
whether they would respond to specific
treatments and maybe give that
information to doctors before they
decide on a treatment and hopefully help
them make better decisions about that so
what we did was we went and took
existing data from many many clinical
trials uh we trained a gradient boosting
machine we used xg boost in carrick
terror it's an awesome library uh please
do check it out if you haven't already
used it um and we use that to basically
try and predict using pre-pre treatment
information uh whether someone would
respond to a specific treatment in the
future you can then productionize it you
you know wrap the model in in some kind
of api or some kind of binary uh and
implement it in production uh and then
we found that two people who did take a
treatment that was recommended to the
treatment that was predicted to work are
actually two times more likely to
recover with that treatment than if you
know they've taken a treatment that was
selected by the psychiatrist based on
clinical intuition
uh and so there's this you know uh even
when someone gets access to care there
is this clear opportunity for us to make
smarter decisions to make um to make
better use of the treatments that are
available to us uh already
a second example that i want to talk
about is really on the operational side
um again touching on this concept of a
vital sign in mental health and tracking
outcomes so if you're really interested
in this one i suggest another landsat
paper this one was not done by spring it
was done by one of our advisors called
jamie delgadillo based in the uk uh in
the uk they deliver psychological
services through a program called iaps
which is basically a government-backed
program
that standardizes the way that they
deliver mental healthcare and one of the
amazing things that they do is every
time you go in for a session uh before
that session starts you take a short
questionnaire to basically try and
measure you know how many symptoms you
have whether you're whether your
symptoms are good whether your symptoms
are bad uh and then on the back end they
can structure and analyze all of that
data and use it to set clearer
expectations for the provider and for
the patient about treatment about
treatment outcomes about whether things
are going well about things are not
going well they use a couple of our
packages lme4 and ln and lme to do
growth curve modelling on on this data
they take nationally representative data
they can say look when people come in on
average they have a you know a
depression score of 20. uh you know on
the second one it's gone down a little
bit on the third one it's gone down a
little bit and you can kind of model out
that growth curve
and then they can say like let's look at
the you know the deciles here what is
the trajectory of the worst 10 of
outcomes and what is the trajectory of
the best 10 of outcomes let's say okay
this gives us the kind of the bounds of
of what we know is normal if anyone's in
that worst 10 of outcomes at any time
let's tell the clinician let's let's
tell the clinician and let's ask them to
do something about it let's have that
conversation with with the patient say
hey you know usually by now people have
seen this much progress and it seems
like we're only seeing this much
progress you know is it that you don't
like the therapist is it that you want
to try a different style is it that
something has happened in your life
that's made your symptoms worse but you
know to kind of accelerate that
conversation and give the the provider
and the patient an opportunity to course
correct their treatment much sooner
and when this approach was tested in
clinical trials you can see on the
right-hand side these are two um
two km curves uh and basically you see
that the curve for the green line goes
down much steeper than the curve for the
orange line uh which basically tells you
that that the treatment has a two times
lower failure rate people are much less
likely overall to fail treatment or to
not recover for treatment if you don't
do this
so essentially it's another opportunity
where you can use data you can use uh
you know things like data science and
things like ah to do informative
analyses that really enrich that that
patient and provider relationship that
have really important impacts on
treatment outcomes overall
and the third example third and final
example that i want to uh go a little
bit deeper on uh is this issue of pay
for performance um
and so
uh for context in most of healthcare
providers get paid fee for service uh
and that means that you know if you go
and see your doctor every week uh you
you know you pay them whatever 100 bucks
a week every time you go and see them
and what it means is really if you stay
in treatment for longer providers make
more money
and in mental health
we don't even really measure or
demonstrate quality there's no real
concept for quality uh certainly not in
a kind of regular care or treatment as
usual and so what it means is that
providers are really not incentivized to
help you get better faster because
actually you know if you leave you know
if you get better and then you leave um
they now need to go and find a new
patient or they're kind of losing
revenue and so you have this like hugely
misaligned incent problem of hugely
misaligned incentives
and really in an ideal world what we
would like is for providers to help
patients get better as fast as possible
and the providers who can help patients
get better fastest should get paid more
because that means they're doing a
better job right so kind of introducing
this concept of quality and also trying
to move away from a pure
service model uh where incentives are
maybe not necessarily aligned between
the payer and the provider and the
patient
and so the work that i'm going to talk
about uh is from three people uh who all
worked at spring
um the first one is sahar who's a
research scientist at spring she drove
most of this work and so all of the
credit should go to her uh kayla moderos
used to work at spring and they did an
awesome job uh prototyping this out
they've done it in the past in different
areas of healthcare and now they've
moved on to another area of healthcare
working on weight loss and kelsey quick
is a senior director of provider ops at
spring and so um
really brought a ton of domain knowledge
about how can we communicate this
information to providers and how do we
kind of
develop the technology more thoughtfully
and like kind of hand in hand with
providers rather than this being like a
punitive pay for performance scheme
and so basically there's four kind of
components to the to the program
the first is that they developed this
software called candela uh candela
basically goes and pulls from all of the
different systems that we have in the
background uh things like the scheduling
tool things like the electronic health
record uh things like patient
satisfaction all those kind of things
and it kind of develops 12 key kpis
around care so clinical and operational
metrics that that we can agree on with
the provider are important right so for
example what is the wait time the wait
time should be lower uh what is the what
is your average what percentage of your
patients actually improve when they go
into treatment okay we all agree that
that number should you know higher is
better and so we kind of go through you
know these 12 different kpis and we all
are on the same page look these kpis are
really important and we're clearly
agreed on what the targets are for each
of those kpis
once we track all of that we then go and
report all of this information back to
the provider every month so providers
who historically have never had any
information uh about the care that they
deliver kind of flying blind uh you know
generally lacking lacking clear feedback
um now receive a monthly report that
tells them here's how you performed on
all these different performance you know
last month you treated this many
patients and this is how many of them
have made progress and this is how many
of them you know said that you're a 10
out of 10 and they're really happy and
they have a great therapeutic alliance
with you and then we benchmark all of
those data points against all of the
rest of the network so spring has
thousands of providers and so we'll not
just give you your data but we'll help
you understand the context so you know
uh maybe your wait time is two days and
everyone else's wait time is three days
and so therefore you know your wait time
is good
the third part is once they've once
they've kind of burned in and they've
started to receive this uh this feedback
so they know where they stand they start
to become eligible for this bonus
program and so we say hey look this is
where you're at right now in four months
we're going to be paying bonuses based
on these metrics so if you you know do
really well on these metrics and you're
in the top 10 percent of the top 20
you're going to start getting paid a lot
more and if you're in the bottom 20
you know we should do something about
that and so every quarter they get these
cash bonuses to the to the highest
providing
highest performing providers um
and so you know that in itself is
obviously um
motivating for many of the providers and
then the fourth piece which i think in
many ways is even more important is that
we coach the providers we don't just
give them the data in isolation but the
providers receive ongoing actionable
feedback on the ways that they can
improve the care that they're delivering
and this overall will raise the bar for
the for the provided network and
certainly that was the hope um so it's
not just about trying to kind of find
the best providers and pay them the most
and kind of make the super elitist
network it's also about you know what
are the ways that we can coach and kind
of raise the bar of the network overall
by giving people structured feedback and
coaching them to improve over time
i think it's working for two reasons and
the first one is that it really
validates and retains helps us retain
the top providers and so you know
there's uh every quarter they get these
medals depending on how well they do
based on the benchmarks and the network
and and they're really proud because you
know they're getting data and being told
that they're really good at their job
for really specific reasons and so we
get all of these linkedin posts where
people are really happy about it people
send us emails saying thanks and they're
really interested in it
and then the final thing is that it is
actually raising the bar and so
when we go and look at
as providers roll into this program and
they start receiving that feedback we
then continue to track all of the
metrics over time and you see this clear
effect where obviously you know the best
providers i think the best providers are
you know they know what they're doing
already and so uh for the top quartile
of providers the results are pretty flat
suggesting that there's maybe not too
much room for them to continue to
improve when they're already doing a
good job but for all other quartiles if
you look at in each of those different
samples you see a continued improvement
so as the providers start to have eyes
on some of these metrics like this is
what my remission score is this is what
my improvement is this is how long it
usually takes me to help the patient
recover you see sustained improvement
month over month and so we're really
showing that we can raise the bar and
help train these providers to be better
at their job and help help them deliver
better um better results over time
almost all of that was built in r as
well which is pretty wild on the
left-hand side you could just see like a
little example of some of the metrics
that they get and kind of explains it
with percentiles and graphs and tracks
it out over time and then on the on the
internal side we have all of these
dashboards that we can use to try and
help you know um find providers that
might be particularly good at treating
uh particular problems but almost all of
this was built in r so if you are a fan
of r uh pretty much the whole stack uh
uses things like our studio team shout
out to our studio for the team and
connect product connect platform has
been a game changer for us we use a lot
of our markdown and parameterize a lot
of those reports uh obviously shiny and
flex dashboards are also huge and tidy
versus
everyone's bread and butter these days
i'm perfectly on time which is wonderful
uh mental health is a field of
opportunity um i think that you know on
one side it's obviously sad and it's
restrained to see people uh find it hard
to get access to care find it hard to
actually recover and feel hopeless when
they're on that journey
but they're you know the upside of that
or the flip side of that is that there
is a lot of opportunity for us to do
better and so
um you know i encourage anyone if you
know if they're interested in this space
to to try and see what they can do to
help improve mental health care but
there's lots of technology out there
there's lots of data out there that we
can use to help people get better
outcomes there are lots and lots of
places where you can use this i don't
think that it's all about treatment i
think that you can do this kind of stuff
in prevention i think you can do this
thing
this kind of framework in marketing
their mental health is a whole um
a whole landscape that that generally
has lacked data historically and i think
there are many places where you can
bring data where you can structure data
and where you can use it uh
at the point of operations to to make
better decisions and and it's important
to know this is no longer just r d this
is not just happening in academic
settings it's happening every day
happening in the real world it's
happening with real patients like the
testimonial that i uh that i shared at
the beginning and so yeah if anyone's
interested in doing this kind of work we
are hiring uh data scientists at all
levels so would love love to hear from
you and uh if not then you know hope you
enjoyed the talk thank you very much
adam
i know your talk a few years ago was one
of our best received talks i was very
happy to have you come in here and do
this again and i loved seeing all the r
you're using that was very very exciting
to see that was super cool and adam
mentioned he's hiring so if you go to
rstats.ai
job dashboard you will see they have
about five jobs posted right now on the
rstat site